on this episode we had a really good
time
are you out
hi
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 221 of
the askgaryvee show
our first guest in our new deluxe office
and I'm super excited bout it we didn't
even talk about the white on white which
I'm very excited about I thought your
show my show you're showing some
biscotti I came from I like a six-day
trip by myself I'm allowed to show my
chest hair which is ten you want twenty
six days by yourself days that's where
this campus why'd you go I went to I
went for food Greece and I went to Italy
and I went from Pisa to Florence to
Siena multiple channel Chianti
if Perugia Rome Rome Positano Knoxville
sorrento/positano/amalfi cosa Mexico's
Capri then Cecilia Cecilia Santorini
Santorini in New York you drank a lot of
wine yes good and I'm just a beautiful
woman very nice a lot of great people
nice yeah guys what a great show see you
guys later all right for you know I know
a lot of the audience is going to know
who you are why don't you address that
like where you came from but I also know
your it seems like maybe this 26 day
trip it has a little bit to do with the
transition I think you're expanding and
so I'd love for you to spend a few
minutes to create context for everybody
thanks Tyler
this is a very interesting time of my
life because just just recently well in
the beginning of the year there was a
part of me that was um everything that I
do I have to be obsess about and all in
no no I think that you can be good at
many things you want to be passionate
you can only be great at things you're
passionate about yep and I've been doing
real estate for about 10 years now I'm
part of the show men are listening who
just finished his last was season 5 and
you've been on since season 2 - yes so
you even four seasons of the chevrons
together but at the beginning of this
year there was something about me that
was I consider myself to be a very happy
guy and when when the years started I
was there was there was a part of me
that was very very sad that normally you
you're in a situation and you can
identify why your son you lose something
you miss something your girlfriend
leaves yourself at this particular
moment I did not know what I was sad
about and I think I've been sad for
quite some time right it was very good
at convincing myself that things could
be worked out but at this point it just
it just seems to be the one time that I
just couldn't convince myself and I
spent eight days under my sheets without
without waking up and not to me was very
strange the fact that I couldn't point
out exactly what would know what the
reason why was and one day I remember I
can't this was the beginning of the year
I came to I was shooting the next day
two million dollar listing where you sit
down on the interview chair and you
explain everything that's going in the
scene and I called a friend of mine I
said listen I I don't I don't want to
show them I'm very very sad in the fact
that I'm understand why my sad about it
makes me even Saturday I don't I just
don't understand because I want to fix
it
and at some point I start crying and
crying but like I've never cried in my
life and when I had nothing left I sort
of saw something and I said you know
when when you're hungry your stomach
growls so you feed it and then it stops
I think the mind works it like that in
some sort of capacity where it's it's
it's instead of growls or roars whatever
they whatever that becomes sad but we
don't know we can we can feed it so
there's something that was missing I was
trying to understand what that was at
that point when I've already sort of
lost all and I was about to open the
door that I did that I already knew it
was behind it but I didn't want it to
open and for once I realized what was
making me sad but I never could have
point out at that specific thing because
it was something that was considered the
perception-wise by the rest of the world
to be the only thing that I could not be
sad about which was my job right because
it was the biggest year my biggest year
in my 10 year career I was I was in the
show that people would kill to be a part
of that was I was that era giving like
giving you unbelievable an exposure to
get deals yes yep but you were finished
each and when I say finish it I'll tell
you why I said it it happened to me in
the wine business when I went one when I
built at the time the biggest wine shop
in America I didn't care anymore
it happened me in sports I do not like
the Yankees and the Rangers anymore
I look at Madison Square Garden and I'm
not excited to see the Rangers play
because in 1994 they won a championship
and I felt that's it I'll never
there's nothing blows your participles
so my the Rangers play it
as a fan okay they won the championship
and that's it they can't win any like
they can win more championships but it's
not a higher level and so the two teams
of the four teams I grew up loving the
Yankees and the Rangers that won
championships I stopped caring but the
Jets and the Knicks it's just it's just
the thrill of the hunt
yes it's just a climb and you know and I
don't know if this is what happened to
you but this is more for the audience
for me whether it's whether it's the
market saying so or I'm saying for
myself when I feel like I've got to the
mountaintop I need to go somewhere else
it's not like you know I don't know but
it doesn't have to be that you sold the
most volume of homes y'all around the
world it just for you
you've hit the highest point and I was
doing is that true yes I just feel that
the reasons I'm doing what I'm doing
today is very different from the same
from the reasons I I started doing this
when I started when I started I was I
was passionate about it because for the
first time I was able to do something
that everybody told me I was not able to
do with other conventional ways about
bringing an education and everything in
between and I became very good at it
because I was passionate about it but
there was a point that the dynamic and
uh and and everything used was the same
I mean the clients were bigger the
numbers were bigger but it was the same
way it was exactly the same so my mind
was no longer stimulated and I felt like
I was just have you figured that what
you want to do adds no idea I'm excited
the 26 days was maybe to try to find out
or just to enjoy it know it was a way to
explore myself as when I went by myself
and what I learned a lot of things first
of all I you know I it's you know it's
very interesting that you have a gut
feeling and most people are you know
when I when I discovered this when I was
on the phone with my friend that night
and I discovered that my what I what I
was doing was not what make me happy it
made me feel relieved but it made me
feel scared because what I realize that
this is not what I like to do and
knowing myself I know that I'm not going
to spend and they don't
in that online because one thing you can
never take back as time I knew that I
had to leave it but I was scared but you
know if he ain't scary I think we're
doing something wrong of course and at
that moment I said you know what [ __ ] it
the next day I went to the interview
chair and I I talked to the producer
nights I put all the cards on the table
just to put myself in a situation where
it was already a suffocated out there
was no way I could turn back and turn
around and going out and eating I
realized that we must do this all the
time we you know we will always be in a
situation I think that we will cut out
and we Lulu yeah we start from scratch
again with everything well we've learned
you're either with look you're either
moving forward or backwards 100% it's
binary just is what I discover it is and
Guerra you and I don't know each other
that well but you know being somewhere I
think is something very powerful and
I've realized that people when they
someone when they when they see the show
I was not the one that saw the most but
people would stop me on the street
they'll never say oh that was a nice
price per square foot you saw last week
no one ever from Australia to Sweden to
the United States everybody that watch
in the scope that we have of viewers
everybody always said the same thing I I
just is not what you do is how you do it
sure inspire the [ __ ] out of me yeah I
want to go on a date and I'm afraid I
rewind your episodes and I just watch
you do you think because it's not what
you do is is the way to do it so I
realize have the ability to connect with
people and to inspire people especially
the fact that I'm young and I can
inspire all the generations and newer
generations I think there is something
much bigger than just broke brewing
transactions because I the realities I'd
never and will never aim for money money
what just happens to come with and
that's what I realized and I said I
wanted to do you know did you save some
money so you can go on this journey I
spend it all in Italy no it's like what
are you I was like look you've sold some
homes you've bought some real property
des you know so you've got a little the
nest egg to give you time to figure it
out it I don't know if you know this is
a Q&A show so we're gonna let India ask
the first question
listen I told her I told her earlier
today that she might find her husband
today
all right good yeah I'm good
push pull push full sales asks how do
you balance professionalism and
personality especially since we're both
so high-energy
how do i balance I don't I can swear I
was gonna say yes I thought I thought
you were going to I don't know actually
that's actually funny moment we need to
look at that clip I thought that's what
you were gonna say but so I'm like you
know what I'm gonna get this in quicker
basically what just happened yeah I
think so I think that's the real answer
it's a blend the whole thing is you know
I don't think I'd only not something is
professional I mean there's there's a
way to describe or categorize or
professionalism but I think it's it's
something you do in your life and
whether you almost the market gets to
decide who decided that cursing was not
professional like who I liked like the
church 5,000 years ago I don't know and
that's fine shirt is not professional
hundred percent full thrower how many
square feet is this I know you down the
tenth oh I think we're know I think it
would crate how many square feet is this
office I think we have fifty thousand
one and a half so this is 32 announcer I
think that's right pretty cool right
yeah amazing great obviously I don't
I definitely gather you those I I'm the
least as I reflect my big my biggest
thing is I want to make sure I don't
become a character sure of myself like
one thing that I'm proud of if you ask
me over the last two or three years is
I'm not doing stick for stick like I'm
in my zone but like my belief is it
should go completely outerspace plus the
best part is I love underestimated like
I love being underestimated and then
delivering like the climb that's all it
is for me is the climb everything's the
climb and so for me I think I probably
even forced it subconsciously early on
that I wasn't going to dress the part
I'm also larger to you I'm just yeah I'm
just not in comfy yeah you're just so I
think I think I think professionalism
gets to be JA I for one do not judge
somebody as being professional or not
professional depending on how they dress
or how they talk or how I just care we
can win
you know I just want to win I don't care
what they look like Ivan the Patriot
fans I'm like - sorry - oh yeah Nora
this person actually don't know why
because it's the greatest thing was it's
super important ever made I my first
time I can you there's nothing so much
snapchats yeah he can break and and my
crew knows what to do yeah get in their
face why first down with it I thought I
didn't understand that most people that
is going on but then when you understand
that you abuse you see the ability of
telling stories and tumbly on the UNAM
then you can leave without it I got like
30 minutes of content every single day
when I went to you telling really I took
everybody on everything good background
less and like that drama get very
philosophical let me tell you where
instead of India
David David asks how do you overcome
objections based on perceived lack of
experience looking young
we both had this - go ahead you go first
on this one I think that there is you
know you can argue with something
generally and I think if you care and
and you're serious about whatever it is
that you're doing and you're really
passionate about it no one can argue
against that and when you're young it
can be three years old and looking at
you you can actually look like a
three-year-old boy and but the when you
speak from the heart
there is no age to that and I think
people will respect that because so
nobody can argue against something that
is real let me go in in the interesting
direction dying to hear what you think
of this I think it just doesn't matter
and let me explain I actually think that
a lot of people didn't take my wine
advice when I was 24 and looked seven I
think you know a lot of people you know
even a decorative minute even 10 years
ago didn't take my business advice
because I didn't look the part or
there's an that I actually think this is
a question India audience
Louie's everybody that is actually a
post-game what I mean by that is it's
just I'm no I'm a broken record
it's results when you come with passion
and both must come a passion does it is
it that if we lose we were full of [ __ ]
if we win we were passionate so what I'm
fascinated by with entrepreneurship and
the game and is it's actually it
actually doesn't matter in the beginning
somebody's gonna give you a shot like if
you knock on a thousand doors there's
people that say yes I say yes all the
time to things that make no sense the
Iraq you know like I did oh it's true I
do it all the time winners do that it's
really funny winners are the one that
put winners on yeah and I but winners
also deal with a lot of losing players
but winners and optimists are always
going to give you that shot right one
one episode I definitely saw in the
background working with Lizzie I mean I
know TVs a lot more stage but I'm sure
it's a replication or maybe real I don't
know how you guys rolled you go to that
next game you know like that dude it's a
big dude like winners give you Stephen
Ross one of the biggest developers in
the world there's my business partner
winners give people at-bats and so I
would answer this question of saying
look 90 out of 100 people gonna say no
the game is proving those 90 wrong later
I got an email the other day from a
former client that makes me want to fly
I hate to think that I'm built on I told
you so but I'm built and I told you so I
love that feeling I love that feeling
it's a great feeling and I just think
that that's how people should be driven
recognize that you there's nothing you
and I are gonna say that's gonna change
somebody who wants to say no to that
person because they look young and don't
have experience it's not about who says
no it's about who says yes and then you
have to deliver yes and then when you
deliver everybody looks back and says of
course you had passion there's a million
people running around that had passion
but then they ended up becoming losers
or scam artists because they didn't
deliver and I'll tell you something I
think being young is one of the best
assets someone can have now because when
you have when you have that passion and
you have that that conviction about it
whatever it is that you believe in that
you're pitching or selling or whatever
it is that you're doing
the fact that you look young and
actually there is there's a beauty to it
I think man now like you're saying it's
changing well it's a good year for young
tears with Zuckerberg and the social
networks and snapchat and should be
looking I mean you know Young has never
been more professionally except anybody
who complains about being young now
doesn't realize that much I'm 40
my generation young men for the 10 first
10 years of your business career you
ain't [ __ ] you even have to the video
but about all people feeling and
remember reverse that's right verse
thank you very much all right let's go
Oh video hey Luis
let's talk leads what is the best way
you have found to get leads
besides referrals I know referrals are
great they're an essential part of every
business but what's the single best way
you found to get leads so early in your
career before anybody actually still do
it which is I love more Garland I swear
we are pretty similar bro yeah I believe
I love there is no leads you have to go
take that one go take them and in the
sound of anything voice over the phone
never change
you know if I'm only digitally - how are
we sitting here you emailed me said I
want to be fun like oh you responded I
can to say I'm fast knows yeah
so it was pretty impressive and yeah I
think you know cold calling everybody is
simple [ __ ] you know with women
what is the script there's a book called
the game [ __ ] kind of good and then and
then there's a script for I understand
but you know the person that you're
pitching today will have a different
mood tomorrow will have a different way
of seeing things tomorrow so you'll
never know what they are you going to
catch that person as long as you
yourself and you were very convicted
about exactly what it is that you're
saying whatever it is that you're
getting their attention you will get
their attention if on a bad day on a
good thing while they're having sex
we're getting about you're under the
table it's still London I'm excited I'm
excited for the comments I mean look I
think I think what you're referring to
that's very very important is that and
this is why talking boxing references I
think it I love this guy I think it's
counter-puncher I think it's
counterpunching 100 reasons like where
you help me because we're both sales
people and what sales people know is you
get another at-bat and what yet the
react of yourself even like if we were
actually outside the office we have a
cup of coffee yeah why can we have a
clock with me you just censored yourself
from a glass of wine yet you said hello
job how many seconds ago I thought that
was super interesting just anybody hear
it so yes I drink wine so the tequila
okay oh great I'll try tricular okay so
if we're doing that we're not I mean I
like you because forget this oh listen
I'm extremely likable yeah you know
about that yes this is a big deal I can
see that that's got India India I'm
extremely likable in yeah town canna
with but a minute I'm stunningly likable
I want more I want more all right let's
go nice tat Co asks what's your major
teeth only major key I got the reference
yeah
yes hey I think my major key is you know
only doing the things that make you
happy I think you can only like it I
think when you're happy you're creative
when you're creative you produce when
you produce you see results and you see
results you do it over again you most
people think that they're not creative
and they will not even have the ability
to create that it's not true I think
everybody have the ability to be great
then they may just not know it yet but I
think that when they are in a position
when they're happy and like
authentically happy they can build
things that they never thought they
could so I think that as would be my key
my major key you brought up earlier
which is why a lot of my team smiled
I think self-awareness is the key where
because I think it's similar to you know
it's funny you also said something that
I push against a little bit which is
being great is an interesting definition
depends on how one defines it I believe
that anybody can be the best version of
themselves if they can find the thing
that they were naturally meant to do
that's the best in them right you know
and and I do think that um I think
self-awareness is just that comes with
getting to know yourself spending time
to understand your so I think you know
allows you to be more convict about
certain things and it's funny for me I
never I almost feel like I'm meditating
in parallel with my speed I've never
liked that actually you know I'm feel
like I'm doing it in parallel I do I
love that you like that I think I do it
- I never realized it yeah I what I
haven't done it I'd like to do is a 26
day trip to think about it but Tilly I
do it in parallel I'm in motion and
reflective at all times yes yes I love
that there's easier terms you came up
with syrup for that I think it's been
ourself parallel meditating I don't know
there probably is I'm so under I'm such
an F student people are just laughing
right now they're like no you mean but
yoga yeah of course unless you like that
that's what I do
that is literally what I do I'm
basically auditing in real time it's a
matrix as a moving fastest [ __ ] but as
you're always meditating for the rest of
your life for the rest of my life it's
why I'm so happy in which he hasn't with
us that's why McGrath on you evolves I'm
pulling I'm pulling in opposite
directions but everything is
we're looking for one and everything is
doing everything I love it I love it I
love a more Russian right yeah let's do
it
Chris asks how many jobs have you had
before being super successful and how
was it helped you now a my first job was
a janitor when were you born in 1986
November 13 get the [ __ ] out of here
stop November 14 Wow yeah I was married
on I was daddy never remember 13th Oh
yep yep
interesting November 13 1996 what I was
in you would avoid a me safe oh thank
god god I'm Way better Oh 86 I was like
that looks so good I was like 886 good
that was right before right before AJ
was born so I was getting super pumped
for my birthday and the last one without
my little brain saying it's awesome so
what were we talking about again I got
so excited about her shot so you were
Jim but where were you born in Puerto
Rico right and how old were you when you
came here is 16 great so you come here
at 16 it for LA do to follow okay Laura
and I worked out I worked as a janitor
at night in a community college and I
work at Hollister during the day they
never even put me on the floor I wasn't
a stockroom putting sensors on the
sheriff nice but you know and then what
and then I became then I was a worked
out at a film school working on the
rental department's putting all the you
know they're getting over here I'll get
putting it back in an organized and put
it all together and then we've done that
yeah yes there's something hot it's a
job never defined me I thought I always
I understood what I was doing it and I
was trying to make it you know when I
when I was when I was at most cleaning
bathrooms
I made it fun yes I did I was caught
dancing with mice with my broom at seven
o'clock at 9:00
tell me you're the happiest janitor I've
ever seen but you know they'd actually
allowed me to do something and you know
it I never said no I knew what are you
what are you right what did you do right
before real estate film directing but
that was not a job oh wait wait wait I
also saw this clip I mean it Lizzie
watches this all the time so it's in the
background you had some crazy sick sick
in weird hair yes and you had six you're
like look at you had a successful thing
happen yeah I was until I did a film
that that to me it was it was not a
disaster was a disaster because I wasn't
able to understand storytelling too well
so the picture looks amazing great
cinematography but there was no snow so
you could I couldn't tell a story well
so you could see you can see people you
know having a conversation but there was
no soul mind most too young to do it I
was 19 and I got very frustrated that's
how I started in the much longer story
but we need tip we need to figure out
that story that's it this is fun yeah so
the guest always gets to ask the
community a question so you'll get
hundreds if not thousands of flies on
facebooking and YouTube to your question
from them now based on what I sense here
we have a lot of similar vibes so this
audience is very much in this ecosystem
so you can ask them anything you can ask
them to predict the score of tonight's
Yankees game you can ask them the
meaning of life you can use this for
market research if you really are
curious about something
or just whatever you thought about in
those 26 days I actually would like to
know how many people and I think you
know I think I have you know I were
related to know how many people are
doing or working on something that they
already know doesn't make them happy but
they convince themselves they should say
for the sake of safety is most most so
I'd like to know and please be honest I
like to really know and you know well
send you the links you'll weigh them
you'll get in there this was fun
what's amazing touch me on the show
November 14th I love that Orfeo
what time were you born you almost make
my word read p.m. a.m. oh oh no that's
the beginning of the day okay so we're
good and I was 3:30 a.m. so yeah
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
you